on passe tout de suite à notre second
débat débats de société comme tous les
soirs si vous êtes un fidèle de
l'émission vous le savez on prend le
temps de de se concentrer sur un débat
de société et ce soit on parle du grand
âge et de l'autonomie y aura près de
cinq millions de français de plus de 85
ans d'ici 2050 j'ai fait le calcul j'y
serais presque c'est trois fois plus
qu'aujourd'hui mais la réforme annoncée
par emmanuel macron en 2018 se fait
toujours attendre sandra sérieux
c'était une promesse d' emmanuel macron
une grande loi encadrant la perte
d'autonomie des personnes âgées une
réforme finalement abandonné ce n'est
pas la grande loi que nous espérions
mais dans le contexte que nous
connaissons y compris le contexte
budgétaire il était nécessaire de
prendre un peu de temps pour réparer
cela à la place le gouvernement propose
des mesures nouvelles pour renforcer la
branche autonomie de la sécurité sociale
une cinquième branche créé l'an passé
que beaucoup qualifient de coquilles
vides faute de financements dans le
budget de la sécurité sociale pour 2022
400 millions d'euros sont prévus pour
favoriser le maintien à domicile avec
une revalorisation des salaires des
métiers du grand âge tu es en sorte que
le tarif socle sur tout le territoire
national ne puisse être inférieur à 22
euros et pour cela nous y mettons 282
millions qui vont permettre vous pensez
les départements qui seront tenues bien
sûr d'arriver à cette somme puisque
beaucoup de départements sont en deçà
des 22 euros leur aide à domicile
d'autres mesures sont consacrés aux
ehpad pour répondre aux besoins de
personnel et de médicalisation avec
notamment le recrutement d'ici cinq ans
de 10000 personnel soignant
supplémentaire avec le vieillissement de
la population les besoins sont
importants
15% de la population française aura plus
de 75 ans en 2040 c'était 6 % en 1990 il
faudrait 10 milliards d'euros par an
supplémentaires pour prendre en charge
correctement la dépendance
le défi du grand âge accueille philippe
mille sénateurs et l'air des deux sèvres
bonsoir bien besoin vous êtes vice
président la commission des affaires
sociales et rapporteur de la branche
autonomie de la sécurité sociale
florence legros bonsoir dirais que c'est
général 17 business school spécialiste
des retraites et du grand âge serge
guérin dans soir vous êtes sociologue
professeur lindsay qu'expert des enjeux
de seniorisation de la société ou
publier les quinquas dos c'est chez
calmann-lévy j'y suis c'est ça n'avait
qu'un cadeau ça
bienvenue au club
oui c'est bien assez toujours des bonnes
nouvelles il faut changer le regard sur
le sur le vieillissement et sur l'âge
qu'ils soient grands ou pas et ça sera
l'un des thèmes de notre débat
évidemment fabrique saiss et rester à
mes côtés je ne demande pas votre âge
parce que ça va mettre de mauvaise
humeur de 100 cadres font bien 34 ha oui
c'est ça c'est fait d'une mauvaise vanne
en bref allez on redevient sérieux avec
ce poids du grand âge pour commencer
certaines disent disent même le mur du
vieillissement je les ai donnés en titre
les randonnées en lancement du sujet
parce qu'il m'a frappé ce ce chiffre
plus de 5 millions de français ont plus
de 85 en 2050 c'est trois fois plus
qu'aujourd'hui puis si on va un peu plus
loin environ deux millions de personnes
en perte d'autonomie là c'est deux fois
plus qu'aujourd'hui philippe pouillé je
commence avec vous comment et et moi
j'ai le sentiment que c'est aujourd'hui
qu'il faut évidemment se poser la
question comment imaginer la prise en
charge de ces millions deux français
dont je ferai partie en 2050 oui je
pense que vous avez raison c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il faut prendre ce sujet
à bras le corps les chiffres sont
parlants et on a vraiment besoin
aujourd'hui d'avoir une vision globale
et une vraie stratégie sur la présence
des personnages et de demain voilà donc
comment à partir des outils existants
comment on réadapte comme en créant
créent l'innovation il faut de
l'innovation il faut inventer comment on
mobilise tous les acteurs et voilà une
vraie une vraie de vision entre une
stratégie globale alors que pour
l'instant on est plutôt sur
l'utilisation des ddd mêmes outils pour
lequel on met des moyens supplémentaires
mais on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui ce
sujet là est un sujet qui n'est pas
traitée on attend on attend depuis trois
ans deux ans la loi de 2003 grand âge
est mort depuis gens non mais il ya
vraiment urgence et je pense que ça
clairement aujourd'hui un débat de la
future et les défis aux élections
présidentielles la florence legros là la
question centrale c'est patent l'âge
mais c'est comment on vit ni dans quel
état on sera dans quel état de santé
dans quel état d'autonomie on sera 80 85
90 et plus ça et ça et ça et 2c de la
réponse s'en suit les réformes
l'amplitude de la réforme les moyens à
mettre en oeuvre pour peut-être rebondir
sur ce qui a été dit il ya probablement
très très longtemps qu on aurait dû s'en
occuper je veux dire il ya eu ce coup
quand même dire aux gens expliqué parce
que souvent les gens posent la question
de la certitude ou de l'incertitude
c'est qui a rien de plus certains que la
démographie franchement les gens qui
sont nés en 1960 ont quand même une
probabilité assez forte d'avoir 80 ans
en 2040 donc
donc du coup ça me fait rire et vous
avez raison et ça fait longtemps qu'on
sait ça fait quand même très longtemps
qu'on le sait on sort on a tous lu enfin
sauf les jeunes devaient dire demain qui
était un rapport qui date des années
soixante dix ans sauf erreur de ma part
donc effectivement la question c'est là
on a de la certitude le problème c'est
que de l'autre côté il ya effectivement
une dose d'incertitude sur comment on
sera et c'est probablement un des
effectivement au coeur du sujet par
exemple de l'assurance c'est vrai que
c'est très difficile de faire cotiser
à de l'assurance dépendance des gens qui
sont jeunes alors que on sait à la fois
et vous avez raison que le risque croît
au fur et à mesure des années avec le
vieillissement de la population mais que
ce risque il est très dilué dans la
population donc en fait c'est c'est
effectivement un vrai sujet et puisqu'on
vient de dire à l'instant c'est que si
vous avez des sous un appartement qui
est bien équipé avec toute la
technologie qui va avec c'est le même
question pour le handicap c'est ce qu'on
me disait aussi à l'instant c'est qu'en
fait c'est beaucoup moins handicapant
que si vous êtes mal logés que vous ne
bénéficiez pas des avancées
technologiques évidemment c'est serge
grah là on reviendra sur la réforme
promise par emmanuel macron et on verra
que c'était passé dès le 1er mai dernier
sans doute à la promettre mais est-ce
qu'il ya quand même une prise de
conscience des politiques sur les
questions du vieillissement depuis
quelques années est ce que vous diriez
ça mais peut-être est-ce que cette prise
de conscience si je me resserre dans le
temps elle elle a été renforcée par la
crise sanitaire dont on sort à peine
alors oui non mon général
alors non d'abord en effet premier
rapport c'est le rapport laroque et 1962
déjà il y avait tout on adore faire des
rapports en france et nous ça ça occupe
les énarques enfin au final
enfin voila on savait déjà semble de
choses en effet la démographie et
quelque chose face il ya une vérité elle
est démographique on voit bien donc ça
augmente et où le moment qu'aux vide a
été particulier parce que d'un côté j'ai
souvenir à l'ancien ministre qui
m'appellent pour me demander chose j'y
mets quand on parlait de 75 ans et
combien de gens je suis passé six
millions de personnes aujourd'hui ah oui
quand même tire que les gens n'ont pas
du tout cette impression là bas et donc
et donc de ce point de vue là il ya une
re découverte mais souvent on a parlé de
manière hyper négative tient attention
les petits vieux fragile attention ils
vont mourir voire même ne sortait pas
c'est plus de votre âge il ya eu quand
même mais l'infantilisation de ce public
a donc un peu de découverte assez
tardive et en même temps quelque chose
d'être placé infantilisant puis un peu
de pensée aussi pour les gens et à
l'époque on avait créé les états
généraux la seniorisation dans cette
idée là justement il faut aussi écouter
les attentes des personnels même
sincèrement la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que à force de ne
pas avoir envie de voir et alors ce
gouvernement le précédent et celui
d'avant mais l'allemand à chaque
campagne électorale il ya eu une annonce
très forte donc on va faire quelque
chose et puis la vie fait que l'on fait
pas ou que l'on trouve mieux à faire ce
qui est intéressant d'ailleurs c'est à
dire que un politique vous souvenez
peut-être quelqu'un qui s'appelait qui
s'appelle françois hollande une gav idée
je serai le président de la jeunesse on
pouvait s'amuser personne d'ailleurs je
suis présent la vieillesse et pourtant
ça concerne les jeunes aussi puisque
c'est la question la longévité est un
jeune s'est jamais qu'un futur yeux un
de dons car il ya quelque chose là
dedans d'ailleurs ça me permet de dire
que si on travaillait plus là dessus on
travaillerait sur la question de la
prévention par exemple comment au plus
tôt par exemple l'activité physique
adaptée les médecines complémentaires
j'ai une autre casquette je dirige une
agence qui des métiers complémentaires
et alternatives il ya plein de questions
autour de ça à qui sont la prévention
allait vraiment centrale est derrière
tout ça c'est bazar 2 sort le jour on
arrivera à regarder ce sujet non pas
comme un problème non pas comme une
charge mais un comme une chance
incroyable même pas en 1900 l'espérance
de vie était de 46 cents à c'est ça
aussi d'ailleurs à propos d'espérance de
vie je rappelle aussi qu'il ya
l'espérance de vie il ya aussi
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé c'est
quelque chose elle augmente un peu alors
on n'est pas les meilleurs en europe
nous où on est on est les plus vieux
l'espérance de vie la plus longue en
france l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
on est plutôt septième pour les femmes
deviennent pour les hommes mais ça
progresse un peu c'est un an 0,6
d'ailleurs je m'en souviens plus loin on
est à combien 2-2 en espérance de
l'espérance de vie globalement à as un
petit peu baissé avec les fécos vide et
globalement ses 79 ans pour les hommes
85 ans pour les femmes ok merci de me le
rappeler j'avais pas si je peux me
permettre jusqu'à lévis les 5% les plus
riches pour les hommes ces quatorze ans
de plus d'espérance de vie que pour les
5 % les plus pauvres n'ont qu'a aussi
toutes les problématiques sociales et
aussi toutes les promesses hier
géographique la france périphérique elle
vit pas là elle vieillit pas la même
manière que le centre-ville ainsi dû
d'où l'importance d'une réforme
ambitieuse vous parliez de justement de
feu la réforme de la dépendance a hissé
c'est là dessus vous avez choisi de
chroniquer ce soir le frère issa hisser
sur ce thème on peut parler de quoi de
de serpent c'est ça repart est
régulièrement un fil des quinquennats
vous l'avez dit emmanuel macron l'avait
promise en 2018 cette réforme du grand
âge finalement elle n'a pas eu lieu
alors il sait pas c'est évidemment des
choses depuis dans ce quinquennat et
quelques mesures ont été prises mais pas
de loi fondamentale françois hollande
l'avait promise lui aussi lors de sa
campagne de 2012 ça n'a pas eu lieu au
cours du quinquennat de françois
hollande et même nicolas sarkozy en
parler lui-même est écoutée en 2011
c'était après un lapsus assez
embarrassant en 2011 nous poursuivrons
le chantier que nous avons ouvert pour
alléger les distorsions de concurrence
dans l'agriculture moi je peux accepter
les distorsions de concurrence avec la
chine et avec l'inde pas avec
l'allemagne
a aucune raison
c'est totalement incompréhensible et je
le dis pas simplement cher philippe
richert parce que je suis en allemagne
en je suis en alsace
c'est là où vous voyez que j'ai raison
de m'investir dans le chantier de la
dépendance
un chantier qui est resté inachevé au
cours de ce quinquennat comme pour les
suivants c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on
en parle aujourd'hui est que les
candidats promettront pour 2022 à
nouveau certainement une loi sur
l'autonomie et le grand âge là vous me
direz ce n'est pas la seule réforme
comme ça qui reparaît de temps à autre
comme un serpent de mer le droit de vote
des immigrés aux élections locales par
exemple ça faisait partie des promesses
de françois mitterrand dans les 110
propositions n'a jamais été fait par par
la gauche autre serpent de mer la
fameuse dose de proportionnelle aux
législatives là encore promise par
nicolas sarkozy par françois hollande
par emmanuel macron lui-même ça n'a pas
non plus été fait alors pour ces deux
derniers on voit assez bien pourquoi
c'est à ses clients il ya des questions
constitutionnelles
en revanche pour le grand âge à première
vue on se dit que c'est relativement
consensuel qui est contre mieux traiter
nos aînés débloquer des fonds sauf que
évidemment ça coûte cher on l'a vu 10
milliards d'euros environ par an à
horizon 2030 comme si la hausse y est
bien pour l'autonomie le quoi qu'il en
coûte étaient encore derrière nous
florence legros ça peut sembler étonnant
d'ailleurs parce qu'on vient de vivre
une période d'un an qu'on dit on dit
d'argent facile mais en tout cas où
d'argent magique donc pourquoi pourquoi
on peut pas trouver 10 milliards pour
pouvoir réformer le grand âge et
l'autonomie est ce que je veux dire
c'est quoi le ressort presque
psychologique qui fait qu'on n'y va pas
à quoi alors d'avancer 10 milliards de
plus oui je sais bien donc voilà on a
effectivement un problème de finances
publiques faut pas le seul aurait après
la colline il ya aussi
le fait que tout ça est très compliqué
techniquement je pense qu'il faut quand
même le dire c'est qu'en france on a un
modèle hybride de financement donc avec
quand même une grosse pas qui est
assurée par la sécurité sociale etc
6.2 reste à charge comme étant ce qui
est plus enquiquinant parce que la
sécurité sociale en fait beaucoup il
faut quand même le dire sur déjà là et
puis effectivement psychologiquement
c'est ce que vient d'évoquer serge
guérin je suis le président de la
jeunesse honnêtement entre nous c'est
pas très enthousiasmant la vieillesse et
la dépendance franchement c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que les
discours politiques n'osent plus
prononcé le mot vieux en valeur des
archives de l'ina dans les années
soixante soixante dix on disait les
vieux il y avait aucun problème à dire
ça maintenant ça a presque l'air d'un
gros mots c'est ça mais moi j'ai
participé à une un colloque il n'y a pas
très longtemps et on nous avait interdit
de dire le mot vieux d'accord avec gm
écrit dans le temps un livre qui
s'appelait vivent les vieux j'ai reçu
des courriers les uns dix ans a enfin
quelqu'un qui dit deux mots et les
autres quasiment me traitant de raciste
quoi parce qu'il ya une représentation
là aussi où pas de vieux les vieux c'est
en plus les autres alors les vieilles
encore plus rude donc il ya vraiment
côté non c'est pas bien donc on va
trouver le terme senior situent les
aînés alors les gens m'aiment desire and
their n'dia interne par part par des
canaux sao les cas les cadeaux à sylvain
génération lésiné vous voulez un peu les
trois oui c'est vrai ça change les
halons je suis comme la dépendance
et je précise parce qu on parle de
sommes pour les personnages et nous
parle de 10 milliards mais si on regarde
l'autre volet qu'est le volet du monde
du handicap c'est entre 7 et 8 milliards
supplémentaires dans voilà donc la
dépendance c'est pas d'enjeu de 10
milliards c'est un enjeu de 15,6
milliards et lorsqu on réorganise
lorsqu'on revoit le tous ces enjeux là
il va en prendre en considération
l'ensemble de la problématique alors on
va quand même écouté mais le maquereau
parce qu'on en parle depuis tout à
l'heure de ce cette promesse 2018 il
avait su trouver les mots c'était lors
du 42e congrès de la mutualité française
13 jeux 18 la dépendance est là et ce
nouvel âge vulnérables de la vie est en
train de s'installer ne pas le voir ou
considéré que ce serait la sphère de
quelques-uns
c'est ne pas nous traiter dignement nous
mêmes c'est ne pas traiter dignement les
femmes et les hommes qui une fois encore
ont la charge au quotidien
de femmes et d'hommes qui vivent parfois
leurs dernières heures leurs dernières
semaines et dont ils sont
celles et ceux qui les soignent bien
souvent la dernière famille
notre incapacité aujourd'hui à répondre
à ce défi
a construit de la souffrance sociale
dans les ehpad chez les personnes
dépendantes ou pour leurs familles nous
devons regarder cela en face
c'est un échec collectif
philippe couillet boudiou duster il me
manque une vision sur sur ce thème la
vision globale quand vous discutez avec
vos collègues de la majorité
présidentielle un pas de la majorité
sénatoriale évidemment comment justifie
le l'abandon de la grande réforme alors
pour l'instant malaisie coget somme
locaux vides le comité est l'élément
essentiel
l'abandon de la réforme pourtant elle
mais aussi le bouddha des retraites fait
tout au kosovo d'eau de du ddrrr aux
enjeux du programme de macron voilà
c'est cela qu'on vide voilà au delà de
tout ça on voit bien que d'un côté tous
les acteurs étaient en attente beaucoup
de choses étaient déjà prêts dans
l'organisation et c'est un problème de
courage politique voilà donc ce sujet là
est sur la table il va en en fin de
quinquennat bon voilà donc on passe
quand on bascule ont basculé
l'expérience elle pour rené voilà mais
c'est avant tout aujourd'hui voilà
locaux vides et le
l'élément qui qui qui qui donne
l'occasion de trouver des troubles
excusa à quel point c'est une déception
pour le secteur
pour le secteur c'est une grosse
déception parce que je pense
et à la différence entre la loi et ce
qui est produit par le plfss manquant
donc une loi c'est mieux c'est gravé
dans le marbre donc voilà et donc je
crois que là il ya une grosse déception
et puis parce que effectivement tout le
monde attendait le renfort sous forme de
ont dit qu'ils manqueraient 350 mille
personnes dans les ehpad donc c'est pas
rien donc c'est ça veut dire aussi qu'il
faut c'est des gens qui vous formez donc
il faut s'y mettre maintenant enfin on
n'en voit pas n'importe king pour
soigner dans les ehpad sotoco plus les
personnes décédées pas de soir3
aujourd'hui de partir des tacots
n'auront plus la crise du personnel où
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui attractif
dimiti fait que on a des du personnel
qui qui se retire alors à mettre 4 se
sent épiée vous parliez du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour pour 2022 il sera examiné lundi en
séance au sénat en jeu propose un style
journal de me rejoindre s'il n'est pas
trop loin dans l'est dans les coulisses
est ce que je vais arriver derrière le
oui le rideau le rideau s'ouvre
bienvenus autour de six journées pour
nous dire ce qui se passe que le sénat
prévoit en matière d'autonomie dans le
cadre de cette
sur le contrôle de fip la mesure
emblématique de ce budget de la sécu
elle est inscrite à l'article 30 c'est
une réforme de l'offre de services à
domicile et de leur financement thomas
concrètement les structures d'aidé de
soins à domicile vont fusionner mais le
symbole n'est pas là il est ailleurs il
est dans l'instauration d'un tarif
plancher nationale de 22 euros par heure
d'intervention l'objectif c'est de mieux
rémunérer les salariés des entreprises
de services à la personne
autre mesure importante thomas continent
ce texte le renforcement de l'allocation
journalière de proches aidants
aujourd'hui c'est entre 8 et 10 millions
de français s'occupent d'un proche en
perte d'autonomie avec cette réforme ils
pourront bénéficier d'un congé de trois
mois rémunéré au niveau du smic s'ils
remplissent évidemment certaines
conditions l'assouplissement de ce congé
proches aidants était une demande des
associations les sénateurs ils sont
aussi favorables mais de manière
générale pour la rapporteur du budget de
la sécu élisabeth doineau le compte n'y
est toujours pas en matière d'autonomie
écoutez là je vais être très sévère nous
n'avons pas eu ce rendez vous sur
l'autonomie qui était prévu on nous
avait annoncé force de 2,2 commande
annonce un renvoi une grande loi nous ne
l'avons pas et on nous envoie des cartes
postales on manque totalement de
stratégie et de vision et surtout de
financement réalité de cette
autonomie qui l'a démontré à travers les
rapports tu as besoin à travers les
rapports la besoin vraiment d'un
financement très important puis je
retouche plus dans un moment seront
examinées lundi pendant les débats en
séance les sénateurs demandent notamment
la création d'une grande conférence
nationale des générations l'objectif
c'est notamment de faire le point sur
les grands enjeux de vieillissement de
la population française merci au style
pour ces précisions fille bouyer cette
conférence nationale des générations et
l'autonomie ça pourrait prendre quelle
forme et du pour nous c'est surtout de
remettre sur la table le débat de
l'urgence de mettre en place cette loi
grand âge nuit voilà alors la forme on
la définit des saynètes avant tout des
financeurs mais c'est surtout pas la
donnée rendez vous puisque comme on peut
pas par le palais fait c'est se créer
cette cette loi sur l'autonomie la
cavale at 45 nos limites dont l'idée
c'est vraiment de porter ce message en
disant voilà c'est une conférence à
défaut d'avoir ce gros chantier doit
enclencher rapidement j'ai râlé les
grands enjeux est comme ça a été évoqué
oui on apprenait quelques exemples sur
le lait les nouveautés ou les apports de
ce texte de loi nous aurons bien les
choses ne sont pas organisés un exemple
flagrant on consacre des moyens
financiers pour du temps de médecins
coordonnateurs supplémentaires dans les
ehpad on en a besoin sauf qu'aujourd'hui
on est incapable de trouver des médecins
sur le territoire donc on voit bien
qu'on crée des moyens financiers par
avoir des besoins exprimés on est
incapable de gérer et de concrétiser ses
engagements et c'est une énumération
finalement de mesures complémentaires et
tant qu'on n'aura pas une remise à plat
complète de l'organisation comment on
crée le lien entre le domicile les
établissements comment on travaille sur
la sacha tant qu'on n'aura pas vu ça et
bien finalement on ne fait que des
apports qui coûte de l'argent on met de
l'argent supplémentaire et on répond pas
aux besoins aux problématiques des
personnes qui disent aujourd'hui à dans
les métiers du grand âge il ya 260
milles à peu près professionnels
ils ont il en faudrait 350 milles d'ici
à 2025 ça c'est des chiffres qui ont été
données par le ministère des solidarités
delà de la santé soit 350 milles
supplémentaires c'est ça c'est ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure est ce que la
question de la rémunération elle est
centrale où est-ce que c'est pas
forcément le point le point le plus
important
c'est probablement un facteur
d'attractivité du métier mais hors du
coup et comme c'est des métiers enfin la
dépendance est très gourmand en main
d'oeuvre en plus pour l'instant donc
c'est aussi ça qui rend que qui rend les
choses extrêmement cher il ya l'effet
prix et puis les faits quantité donc
c'est quand même un problème
effectivement donc à la fois naviguer
entre l'attractivité du métier et puis
le coup le coût du financement
petite parenthèse sur les congés pour
les aidants de proximité dans un alors
hausser nos discussions mais dans une
des circonstances où on demande aux gens
de augmenter leur durée d'activité pour
financer leur retraite je suis pas sûr
qu'ils aient une toute petite
contradiction d'accord
il ya plein de choses à juste je reviens
sur les aidant à ce qui a été dit c'est
la 11 millions d'aidants la moitié sont
en activité les autres sont des
personnes à la retraite qui souvent est
d' un compagnon ou compagne voir
apparent puisque vous pouvez voir deux
générations de gens qui sont la route
est donc allée des fatigues avec tout ça
et on s'est amusé le mot amusés entre
guillemets il ya semble d'année à dire
mais fait les ai donc sais combien c'est
qu'ils aient finalement au début il y
avait rien aucun chiffre avec un groupe
des dents on était arrivé à 260
milliards d'euros si on les payait pas
19-22 roma 19 euros je n'ai pas de
copine c'est pas ça le sujet mais pour
montrer que sans les aidants t'approches
le système de santé s'écroule quand même
un vrai sujet et donc quand on parle de
tout ça faut pas oublier qu'à ces
personnes là un deuxième élément en
effet je crois que l'élément quand même
c'est qu'on a du mal à faire venir des
gens travailler dans ce secteur là alors
je rappelle aussi mal payés à 90% des
femmes tout ça joue aussi et c'est à la
fois dans le monde des ehpad et et dans
le monde du service à personne puniet
les deux or les gens veulent à très très
majoritairement
vivre chez eux à domicile mais pour lui
chez soi domicile d'abord au bout d'un
moment si vous avez un bouleversement
neurologiques au bout d'un moment vous
pouvez plus institutes mais ça demande
aussi beaucoup de moyens et abandonner
ses c'est trop difficile donc il ya
aussi ça à prendre en compte mais vous
avez parfaitement raison le problème
c'est que peut-être pas que pour ce
sujet là notre cas pour ce sujet là il
ya c'est la politique façon puzzle quoi
je fais un petit morceau all un petit
morceau là un petit morceau là un petit
morceau là alors c'est chouette quand
c'est les tontons flingueurs c'est moins
bien quand c'est de la politique et du
coup c'est aussi on a du mal à avoir une
vision globale de la transition
démographique vous disiez tout à l'heure
on sait les chiffres on sait je vais
juste rappeler une chose au moment où il
ya eu donc le baby-boom ça a commencé en
1946 en 2006 est donc incroyable en 2006
il avait 60 ans et donc comme vous savez
il ya une réforme qui allieront passe de
la retraite 65 80 ans et donc en 2006 a
haussé fou il ya 188 200 personnes de
plus tous les ans qui viennent à la
retraite
2006 + 20 ça fait à peu près 2000 26 on
est d'accord 61 de plus 20 ça fait à peu
près 80 ans c'est le moment où
globalement on a un risque on appelle de
prévalence plus forte d'avoir des
problématiques de perte d'autonomie
c'est à dire dans cinq ou même pendant
cinq ans on a devant le mur aux
questions dont vous parlez il est là et
il est donc la question du recrutement
de ces races édition 2010 est maintenant
il faudrait réformer leur donner envie
de faire ce métier et il essayait de
mémoire 45 % des gens qui travaillent
actuellement ont plus de 50 ans même moi
aussi partir à l'automne en plus des
métiers sont parfois très difficile donc
même physiquement c'est aussi oublier
mes deux niveaux moi j'veux pas qu'on
parle de vision globale la rémunération
est un point important mais là bas que
ça il ya elle fait la promesse aux pieds
carrière aujourd'hui comme vous avez pas
une organisation globale ça veut dire
que vous rentrez dans un établissement
vous avez pas vous n'avez pas de
perspectives de carrière donc on met à
de motivation ne s'était forcément vous
êtes musée donc il ya un vrai travail de
fond est là dessus voilà il ya un vrai
travail de fond parce que à la fois une
réorganisation sur la prise en charge
est passé glissante s'entraîne aussi une
vision globale sur les métiers la
production nation l'évolution comment
moment donné je peux passer un grade
supplémentaire est mieux rénumérés
comment je coordonne le privé le public
va tous ces sujets là d'être mis sur la
table et c'est comme ça avec l'aspect
rémunération que l'on peut réellement
donner des perspectives de carrière
trouver un intérêt sur un métier
extrêmement difficile mais en même temps
pour lequel on a on a des possibilités
et puis c'est de l'emploi aussi pour nos
territoires voilà donc il faut trouver
voilà c'est ont gelé on a besoin
vraiment de cette organisation générale
dans lequel tous ces points là doivent
être traitées et en payant une image
négative de l'âge vous voulez vous
donner envie à des jeunes filles à des
jeunes garçons d'aller bosser dans le
secteur sans l'esprit de tous les jours
car elle a les yeux c'est dégueulasse
comme ça orapi c'est pas bien et puis
c'est du déclin est quand même des gens
qui d'ailleurs regardez vous parler des
élections présidentielles qu'est ce qui
a fait débat c'est on va peut-être
mettre le le droit de vote à 16 ans
comme c'était ça le sujet alors vous me
direz ça coûte rien mais du coup un
répit oui parce que quand même le
système les écuries tout ça vieillissent
billy est ce qu'il ya plus d'échangés
sur le vocabulaire vous avez peut-être
entendu la ministre déléguée à
l'autonomie brigitte bourguignon qui dit
il faudrait peut-être renommée les ehpad
ça serait symbolique d'une réforme
globale d'un changement plus globale
mais vous êtes d'accord il ya peut-être
là aussi quelque chose a changé dans la
perception dans les services publics des
jets qu'on n'aura plus que ça à faire
agir
je ne sais pas faire des réformes dont
je communique voilà donc voilà de conte
et d'un sujet là a pris un big bang à
faire sur ce modèle là c'est clair clair
aujourd'hui à fo urgences où viennent le
dire parce que on a une responsabilité
collective depuis au moins trois
gouvernements les chiffres sont là on a
les éléments on doit régler les points
comment s'organise comment finances
quand même des agrégés comme des
financements à ce sujet là ils sont sous
la table on est raide pas mais par
contre on veut bien renommée les ehpad
et non justement finance comment
finances mais par contre parce qu'on
parle de 10 milliards d'euros est ce que
ça se traduit par une augmentation des
cotisations pour que ça
lui a plu alors les diverses et s'est
offert mais jamais d'ailleurs il ya
plusieurs pistes de travail d'abord un
gala meilleure efficience pour rappel
c'est un système qui a organisé ou
financement une partie par l'état ne
fais partie par les départements on est
des tuyauteries la scène et ça donc déjà
en matière d'efficience vous me dire que
avec de l argent qui est sur la table on
peut faire largement mieux 2 il ya le
débat de du domicile et le domicile
devant bordeaux n'est la présence hors
du domicile même si elle est coûteuse on
peut la traiter différemment avec les
mêmes moyens financiers que l'on
consacre aux établissements ont tout
couvrir des territoires beaucoup plus
large 3 il ya des pistes de financement
nouvelles qui doivent être trouvés ces
débats de l'assurance y lcd badauds si
les complémentaires santé ces débats
aussi comment on fait en sorte que les
plus jeunes générations commencent à
cotiser pour pour le plan pour leur
dépendance future là donc on a des
pistes de travail autour de tout ça le
tout c'est de le trancher il ya un très
bon rapport qui a été fait par son nom
sa tombe de rapport qui donne les pistes
de travail mais voilà on a des
possibilités
le tout c'est que trouver des recettes
financières quand vous n'êtes pas vous
n'êtes pas réorganiser et donc celle ci
pourrait les larges supplémentaires dans
un bateau en difficulté faut pour des
choses en ordre florence legros est ce
que les assurances privées peuvent
prendre le relais où on montre est
vraiment en jeu pour pour financer les
dépenses liées aux ventes c'est une des
difficultés c'est à dire que en fait
c'est un peu technique mais pour que
l'on puisse assurer un risque il faut
que les risques soient indépendants or
là où on a des risques qui sont
dépendants sans fin c'est le cas de et
sans jeu de mots est donc en fait parce
que le risque s'accroît dans le temps et
donc une génération a une probabilité
supérieure à la précédente donc on peut
pas mutualiser entre les générations
donc ça c'est de la première chose la
deuxième leçon modélisation par nos
internautes mais les assurances privées
savent pas faire quoi c'est vrai ça va
faire je dirais qu'elles savent pas
faire en l'état actuel mais ce travail
elle travaille selon des modèles model
mais alors c'est compliqué en plus la
dépendance alors on a réglé ça avec les
gir 1 2 3 4 quant au compte gouttes
maison a pris feu c'est pas compliqué un
expert qui vient il ya plus descendre
bon c'est bon l'assurance la dépendance
ça demande quand même des évaluations
médicales qui sont un peu plus
compliquées et donc tout ça est beaucoup
plus difficile à manier mais ces épis
l'autre aspect c'est que
à 20 ans demandez un jeunes entrant dans
la vie active de commencer avec son
premier salaire à s'assurer pour une
dépendance qui va arriver à minima 60
ans après et encore une fois on a une
probabilité faible et heureusement ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle de devenir
dépendant à la fois c'est un gros
problème collectif et individuel est à
la fois finalement c'est relativement
faibles comme tôt c'est effectivement
comme le handicap est donc demandé un
jeune du reboot et aura peut-être 15 %
de chances de devenir dépendants dans 60
ans commencent à cotiser voilà donc
jeune déjà pense qu'ils ne font
peut-être même pas dans les partis
ailleurs ça c'est un sujet qui savent
plus qui est extrêmement liés parce que
je m'appelle quand même qu'à une réforme
des retraites qui est avorté et cette
réforme des retraites qui était là je
suçais l'économiste un qui parle qui
était basé sur un régime par points
normalement aurait dû aplatir la
pyramide des retraites est donc remonté
les retraites les plus petites retraites
et ça ça aurait été déjà quand même un
bout de solutions parce qu'on rappelle
quand même aujourd'hui en france 6 % des
gens dépendants ont les moyens de payer
de financer leur dépendance avec leurs
revenus oui on a on a cherché le prix
moyen alors le seigneur c'est le prix
médian d'une chambre en ehpad ses 2000
euros par part moi 2004 euros par mois
pour être précis avec évidemment des
grandes disparités selon les régions par
exemple j'ai donné l'exemple des
yvelines prix moyen d ims et 3000 euros
et la pension moyenne en brut 1 en brut
ces 1500 euros donc on est effectivement
le loin du loin du compte dans la
capacité des des personnes à financer
leur place dans une année pas de la fois
la durée excusez-moi la durée moyenne de
dépendances elle est faible c'est 3,8
ans donc nous donc c'est passé pas le
coeur du problème en fait c'est pas le
coeur du problème sauf pour ceux que ça
touche bien sûr et pour lui la ville
d'origine franc mais moyennant plus
voilà avec du sujet quand même si le
débat aussi du patrimoine demandez vous
avez parfois du patrimoine et puis c'est
aussi on est aussi comme dans un pays de
solidarité ses terres pour ceux qui
n'ont vraiment pas de revenus bah vous
avez aussi des capacités pour que la
série t national viennent compléter
j'irai le le kulo saas fee voilà ça se
fait déjà joué enfin quelqu'un qui a peu
de revenus n'est pas donc on lui paye
pas voilà le roi et les classes moyennes
comme toujours la fête qui se retrouvent
et tout le monde n'a pas parce que on
dit oui à 75 % des seniors sont
propriétaires mais tout le monde n'a pas
un 100 mètres carrés au centre de paris
quoi y'a que les gens en moyenne c'est
ses 138 milles euros le patrimoine des
gens donc très vite et puis parfois je
découvre que mon petit pavillon qu'elle
j'ai sué sang et eau pour l'acheter
d'abord je n'ai pas envie de le vendre
ce que j'aimerais bien que ce soit dans
les étages et si je le vends je découvre
que personnes veulent acheter donc c'est
aussi très souhaitable c'est moins vrai
pour moi c'est vraiment difficile et que
donc du coup c'est pas aussi liquide
qu'on lirait ça fait 30 ans qu'on parle
de ce genre de projet finalement ne pas
oublier que le gros des retraités et en
plus ça s'empire 1 puisque les retraites
diminuent le gros des retraités ne sont
pas des gens qui roulent sur l'or qui
peuvent se permettre comme ça de ce pays
chauds ce bâtiment et le service à
personne vous avez pas mal des dettes
sociales avec l'appareil tout ça quand
vous rentrez en maison de retraite
médicalisée pas dire ehpad en maison
l'autonomie en maison de l'accueil des
parents trop race à ce qu'on veut on va
dépenser de l'argent pour ça pour rien
d'ailleurs de ce point de vue affirmé la
garde beaucoup moins des délais mais
devait d'ailleurs sont pas toujours très
très présente et il est pourtant là haut
dit qu'
il ya une silver economy c'est le terme
on avait dit tout à l'heure qui pèse ses
130 milliards d'euros avec une
croissance de 5% par an serge guérin je
reste avec vous est-ce que d'une
certaine façon on appelle ça vous n'avez
pas le sentiment que les entreprises ont
parfois un peu plus vite que les
politiques en inventant des solutions en
cherchant des solutions
pour faciliter
l'axé le logement la culture
l'accompagnement des personnes
indépendantes normalement une entreprise
bien fait elle regarde le marché bah oui
voilà c'est logique et donc comme il ya
un vieillissement elle peut dire tiens
il ya un marché qui s'ouvrent mais un
marché qui se développe la filière
silver economy a été inventé en 2013
dans ce qu il y avait je crois trente
sept filières l es pas aussi fait quand
même beaucoup des filières prioritaires
s'en faisait partie c'est vrai que des
entrevues ce qui faisait de la silver
economy sans le savoir d'ailleurs tout
le secteur des ehpad c'est ça les à
personne c'est ça cabedo
ensemble d'entreprises car et d'autres
qui sont dit il faut qu'on y aille alors
le problème c'est que beaucoup
d'entreprises sont allés plutôt dans une
logique très techno en oubliant un petit
peu assez sociologue qui sort les usages
faire demander aux gens ce qu'ils
veulent quoi et comment ils le veulent
donc souvent on a voulu plan appliqué
des choses puis le deuxième élément on a
créé la conférence des financeurs et
parfois dans les 100 départements il ya
le même projet sauf qu'on va remettre de
l'argent pour expérimenter le projet
institue et là on dépense là pour le
coup beaucoup d'argent parfois devenir
un traître est inutile mais oui il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont dit il
ya un marché le problème c'est qu'à le
marché des loisirs des jeunes seniors
dès qu'un cadeau marne c'est quelque
chose qui d'ailleurs veulent absolument
pas qu'on dise qu'ils sont seniors si on
n'a pas envie d'acheter une voiture de
vieux quoi hein donc c'est aussi donc il
faut adapter tout ça pour que ce soit
plus facile en terme d' usage mecs qu'on
dise pas aux gens c'est parce que tu es
vieux c'est juste parce que ça
correspond mieux à vos usages et puis il
ya pour les plus âgés ou là on rentre
dans d'autres logiques la téléalarme des
choses comme ça mais maria latella
larmes quand même du mal à démarrer est
ce que les gens vont porter un bracelet
électronique sur eux au moment où est
tombée à 6,8 et puis qui va intervenir
parce qu'on trouve beaucoup de
technologies mais encore une fois on
elles prennent des gens qui peuvent
intervenir derrière parce que si la
personne tombe encore faut-il aller à
aider la relever si la personne dans le
coin ainsi de suite donc oui la silver
economy est quelque chose qui se
développe mais qui est trop et c'est sur
une logique très techno et cas beaucoup
oublié la question des usages mais en
effet les entreprises elles se bouge pas
oui et ça évolue enfin moi je connais
également des mutuelles aujourd'hui est
en train d'évoluer enfin on n'est pas
des lourds même la poste mais par
exemple faire la faire de la
surveillance de deux personnages et
voilà donc on voit qu'aujourd'hui il ya
plein de possibilités mais en même temps
de nouveaux comment est-ce qu'on était
comme à ce que l'organisme florence
legros sur ce point de vue sur cette
question de la silver economy de sa
capacité à
oui peut-être plus que les collets
politique qu'est ce que vous en pensez
non je crois que l'essentiel a été
effectivement dit c'est à dire que les
entreprises ont regardé où était le
marché et ont bien anticiper
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie et
donc des besoins évidemment après c'est
pas les mêmes besoins selon qu'on a 50
ans qu'on soit jeune retraité prêt à
sauter dans le premier avion pour le
bout du monde et qu'on est con soit
indépendant oui mais est-ce que ça ce
pardon de vous interrompre encore une
fois mais est ce que finalement si on
commence à se rendre compte quand on a
je sais pas 60 65 qu' on est un on est
une source de richesse pour une
entreprise qu'il ya des startups qui
sont en train de créer à nouveau marcher
c'est peut-être déjà ce regard qui
change sur le vieillissement est ce que
l'on pensait ça a très probablement bien
sûr ça c'est oui le effectivement
surtout quand et c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles il ya un certain nombre
d'acteurs qui disent que s'il faut je
repasse au volet
cotisations et financement que s'il ya
des cotisations ans m c'est plutôt sur
les retraites complémentaires qu'il faut
lui est posée parce que effectivement la
l'échéance est plus proche de tous a
minima on a vu ses propres parents parce
que c'est vrai qu'avec l'allongement de
l'espérance de vie ce que rabelais serge
à l'instant c'est que en fait on peut
être plusieurs à être traité dans une
famille et effectivement quand on a 60
ans on a des parents qui ont 80 90 et là
on voit effectivement les besoins
commencé à poindre donc probablement la
sensibilisation elle passe plus par
l'appareil par leurs aînés ming
trafic de came d'adaptation des
logements par exemple justement ce que
vous y est resté plus longtemps chez soi
encore faut-il que le logement soit
adaptée donc là il ya des pays acp et
prometic très forte d'accès tout
simplement d'améliorer les accès parce
que ça veut dire fils bouyer que l'enjeu
d'une grande réforme c'est de maintenir
à domicile le plus longtemps possible
oui alors d'abord c'est d'écouter les
attentes oui la scène qui vise la
première vue ils sont plutôt cette
logique générale c'est faire la leur et
séchage et donc ça veut dire que c'est
bien une forme globale parce qu'on parle
des on peut parler de déçoit mais c'est
le débat du logement c'est un bon
exemple mais on parle de grande cause
nationale de deux gouvernements la loi
elle en a réduit à 10 % les logements
adaptés qui était prévu donc au niveau
du programme d'aidé logements sociaux on
voit bien que la cohérence d'un côté on
dit il ya un vieillissement de la
population on a besoin d'avoir des
logements adaptés en masse pour l'avenir
et en même temps et bien on diminue la
programmation double bien que on est par
petits bouts par tuyaux il faut c'est
transversal cédés hors jeu de santé
séjour de prévention serge et de
logement georges et de mobilité tous ces
sujets là doivent être traités de façon
globale le taux nominal en vue
transversale et donc on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il ya certes la sécurité
sociale cnss est ce parce que c'est
l'acte financeurs mais c'est un enjeu
global et je pense que dès lors qu'on
leur a intérêt comme étant et bien
impliqué dans toutes les politiques on
aura aussi un regard différent sur le
vieillissement de la population on a
fait ce qui vous rend optimiste je vous
restera qu'à ce qu'on disait je pense
qu'il ya en fait le la question des
vieux c'est la solidarité égoïste gea 20
ans tout intérêt ce qu'on s'en préoccupe
parce qu'un jour je vais être concernés
et avant mes parents mes grands parents
donc ce qui me rend optimiste et que
c'est à un moment donné la quantité fait
qualité quoi quand il ya autant de gens
que ça concerne quand on arrive à plus
de 25% la population qui a plus de 60
ans aujourd'hui et demain ça sera 35 %
de la population en 2050 c'est 35% la
population en 1911 et et on tient à 7%
envoyer les écarts quand il ya 35 % vous
pouvez quand même difficile où vous
mettez les mains dans les poches aller
faire autre chose il a carrément donné
ce qui me rend optimiste et la pression
démographique justement la prise de
conscience l'obligation est d'essayer de
comprendre que encore une fois c'est pas
une charge mais ça peut être une chance
incroyable d'emplois l'aménagement du
territoire d'économie en général de
développement économique est aussi de
rappeler que ces seniors avant qu'ils
soient vraiment en perte d'autonomie
c'est aussi des gens qui contribuent à
la vie sociale sans les retraités vous
pouvez fermer les associations c'est
quand même des gens qui sont là très
présent dans le tissu social je vais te
sens les retraités aisés dont l'addition
des aidants vous êtes sénateur vous
savez comme moi 35 % des mères de nos
communes sont des retraités c'est
parfois des fonctionnaires gratuit oui
une boule oiseaux évidemment beaucoup
plus que la moyenne se donne jusqu'à ce
point
de la moyenne normale en effet ils sont
là donc là aussi cette pression-là et
regarde aussi la télé un peu plus
à ce débat je rappelle le titre de votre
livre les cinq ados c'est chez
calmann-lévy merci frédéric ils sont